ROMAN NURIK: Hello and
welcome once again to
Android Design in Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOSH: Hey guys.
My name's Adam Kosh.
NICK BUTCHER: And my name's
Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And we are
back from hiatus.
We took a nice long break to
give ourselves some time to
prepare for Google I/O 2013, and
now that the conference is
over, we now have a chance to
talk about all the cool things
that were announced, all the
wonderful design sessions that
took place, and that's what
we'll be doing today.
So with that, let's just jump
right in, because we have a
lot to cover since there was
a lot that happened at I/O.
So the first thing we want
to do is look at all the
different sessions
that took place.
There were a lot of design
sessions this year.
I don't know exactly how many--
something like seven or
eight or something.
But they were all jam packed
with different bits of
information on a variety
of different
subtopics within design.
So the first that we want to
talk about is Rachel Garb's
and Helena Roeber's
session, "Enchant,
Simplify, and Amaze--
Android's Design Principles."
So I guess the way we should
probably do this is we should
each talk a little bit about
what takeaways there
were for us.
For me, the big takeaway
here was the
association of emotion--
positive and negative
emotions--
from the session.
Rather, the association of
positive and negative emotions
with UIs and how those
play together.
There's a lot of interesting
things about writing guide and
things like that.
ADAM KOSH: Yeah, and I guess
for me it was interesting
because I think Rachel
introduces the vision as sort
of being touchy-feely.
And for me, it was always hard
to wrap my head around how
that relates to design
for myself, because
I'm more of a developer.
And so I really like the
examples that she gave, like
actually showing how-- like, for
example, one of the ones
here is decide for me, but let
me have the final say.
You can see that.
So, for example, when you're
deleting a message, it deletes
first, and then there's
an undo action
rather than a dialog.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
same for me.
It's how they actually apply
these very, very snappy
principles, and she shared how
they actually helped them
inform their design decisions.
So there's a section in there
where they're assigning
marbles for things you do well
and bad marbles for things you
do badly, and that really helps
you to lay up different
design decisions.
And I thought that was a really
interesting technique.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and they also
mentioned very briefly
the Android Baseline Study that
we conducted about a year
or two ago.
That was kind of one of the
foundations of a lot of these
design principles.
I think it's mentioned somewhere
near the beginning.
So it was a really good
overview of the design
principles, and I think that the
closest page on our design
guide to this session is
obviously the Creative Vision
Design Principles section,
which goes
through all of them.
So they went through that in
excruciatingly good detail.
So that was a good session.
Should we move on
to the next one?
ADAM KOSH: Yeah.
Sure.
ROMAN NURIK: Next was "Agile
UX Research Practice in
Android." This was by Miki
Konno and Bethany Fong.
And so here, they go through a
bunch of different techniques
that the Android team uses, as
well as lots of different
companies out there--
a couple of different techniques
for really
lightweight, really cheap
research, stuff that doesn't
involve millions of dollars
or thousands
of dollars, or whatever.
It's stuff that you
can basically do.
Like one of my favorites
was the Cafe Study.
You go into a Google Cafe or
into a Starbucks or something,
and you just show your app or
show a very specific flow
within your app to a few people
and kind of measure
their reactions in
certain ways.
So it's very, very lightweight,
and very quick,
hence the name agile.
ADAM KOSH: Yeah.
I'll admit I actually haven't
got around to looking at this
particular session yet, but
it's on my to-do list.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, these are
each like 40 minutes or so,
so, I mean, it is a
lot of content.
ADAM KOSH: I've got a lot of
backlog of sessions to watch.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I like the
way that they laid out the
traditional research process,
and it's like this stage
followed by this stage
followed by this
stage, and that's it.
But there's no way that's going
to work in the Android
world where the pace of mobile
app development is just too
agile, and they can really
compress it down.
So I thought it was really
interesting.
They stressed how important to
do research is, but showed how
to do it in an agile way.
It was really, really,
really great.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And in the very beginning,
they had this,
I guess this grid--
not really a grid, I guess a
chart-- of the different
techniques that you could use.
And they focused more on
the qualitative and
behavior side of things.
So right around here.
They didn't really spend too
much time talking about the
other stuff, because sometimes
it can cost more.
Some of it is kind of outside
of the scope of a small
research team.
So definitely, if you're
interested in this kind of
area-- this general area of UX
research, they talk about a
whole bunch of techniques.
And here are, I think, the major
four techniques they
talk about.
They actually also spent a lot
of time on the Pulse Study.
I think they went into
the most detail
about this Pulse Study.
So, yeah.
UX research.
The next session was "Cognitive
Science and
Design." And this is one
of my favorites.
Alex is a tremendously
good speaker.
He was on the show--
in I think it was the
notifications.
It was notifications
and something else.
ADAM KOSH: Google Mail.
ROMAN NURIK: The
design process.
ADAM KOSH: The Google Mail
design process, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: And Google Mail.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So he was on the show, and
he talked about that.
And he's a tremendously good
speaker, and he did a session
on cognitive science
and design.
So he mentioned a couple
of things--
the Gestalt Principles, he
mentioned things like
proximity closure, et cetera.
We could see here this kind
of triangle and so on.
And this is actually really
important, because it's one of
the fundamental bases of the
Holo visual language, kind of
this use of space and topography
to communicate
hierarchy and structure.
And you can kind of see that.
Even without a whole bunch of
lines, you can still make an
association or form a mental
model of the relationship
between these different
groups of circles.
So it's kind of one of the
fundamental bases for the Holo
visual language, so it's kind
of a good session for that.
ADAM KOSH: Yeah.
I think I was saying to Roman,
this session, regardless of
Android or design or anything
else, it's just really, really
interesting to watch.
And one particular slide I
liked-- and I don't think we
have it here, but it had a bunch
of different shapes, and
then they're colored in
different colors, as well.
And he sort of showed how the
colors are very easy to spot
the differentiation, but
the shapes are not.
So, again, it implies back to
sort of the Holo visual
language using spacing and
contrasting colors to
differentiate.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And he also mentioned
affordances.
And I actually really
liked this slide.
There is the previous slide that
showed a bunch of similar
looking trash cans of different
colors, and then
this slide showed trash cans
with different colors,
obviously, but also different
slots, and they afford
different types of things
being put inside them.
So that was a more effective
type of trash slash recycling
combination.
And one other that I really
liked was a slide about
peripheral vision.
So he uses this really funny
analogy of a tiger.
You walk into a room, a test
study, and the first thing you
see is a tiger.
And they did this study, or
something-- or I guess this is
based on a study.
Your response time to things
right in front of you is
actually slower than your
response time to
things around you.
And so your peripheral vision
is very important.
And that's actually one of the
reasons that a lot of things
on Android are near the corners
and edges of the
screen, rather than in
the very dead center.
NICK BUTCHER: You should
watch the talk.
It's phenomenal.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
It's really good.
ADAM KOSH: It's really good.
ROMAN NURIK: It's really,
really good.
One last thing I wanted
to mention, since
this talk is so good.
You also talked about
recognition, so your ability
to recognize people's faces
versus their names.
Your ability to recognize their
faces is something like
almost constant time.
Like, within 100 people, you'll
instantly recognize
your friends.
Versus in a list of 100 names,
it'll take you a while to find
your friends' names.
So really kind of interesting
tidbits here and there.
We've probably spent a lot
of time on this, and
let's just move on.
The next session was also
very, very good.
It was by Jens Nagel and Rich
Fulcher on the Android User
Experience Team.
They're both interaction
designers.
In this session, they basically
covered navigation,
and really more higher
level structure.
So rather than looking at an
app as a set of pixels or a
set of individual screens, they
looked at it as a whole,
and they talked about
different types of--
I guess they used this kind of
use case modeling practice to
look at or to plan out or
map out an application.
So they went into a little bit
of depth on this BarKeeper
app, where they basically looked
at different people and
their different use cases and
mapped them out in this not
really a flow chart, but
more like a diagram.
And this helped them make
decisions about what
navigation structures they
should use in the app.
NICK BUTCHER: One of my favorite
bits of this talk is
where they explain some of the
design decisions behind some
of the Google or Android
stock apps, like the
calendar and so forth.
So they went through the process
of how they arrived at
the particular navigation
structure they used and showed
variations and why they wouldn't
work and so forth.
It was really interesting.
ADAM KOSH: Yeah.
I thought it was just really
useful how they showed--
I think it was several examples
where they show what
an app could look like with
tabs, with the spinner, with
the drawer.
I don't know if they show
examples of the six pack or
dashboard patterns.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
It was almost never
the proper place.
ADAM KOSH: Yeah.
It never turned out to be
worthwhile selecting.
But I thought it was really
useful just because it applies
to any app.
You could go through these
different iterations and see
how it would work with these
different patterns.
And certainly there's pros and
cons to each of them, which I
think was the takeaway.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And I really like how
they separate out
the structure into--
well, they have a couple
of common patterns for
recognizing structure.
So they look at apps that may
have a specific focus--
like one of the top level
sections is the most
important--
and then apps that are very
deep, where they have an equal
weighting of sections,
but each section
itself is very deep.
And they look at another type
of structural pattern, where
an app is very, very
interconnected,
which is this case.
So it's really a good way
of structuring or
thinking about your app.
Rather than thinking about its
features or the individual
components, think about
it as a whole.
Like what are the different
types of use cases that you're
trying to solve for
different users?
NICK BUTCHER: And then, of
course, they spent a fair
amount of time talking
about the navigation
drawer pattern, as well.
And I think Jens made an
excellent point about how this
is a community pattern that's
emerged, and how we've spent
our time taking a look at all
the different community
implementations and what works
well and what we felt could be
improved slightly, and how we've
gestated on that process
and really put a lot of thought
and effort into
providing some guidance that we
hope will really solidify
this space so people have some
stability of expectations of
how this works.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
Yeah.
So the navigation drawer was one
of those patterns that was
introduced in Jens' and Rich's
talk, and Nick and I covered
it later, which we'll
talk about.
But definitely we'll probably
do another full episode of
ADiA on just the navigation
drawer at some point.
ADAM KOSH: There's going to be
a lot of demand for that.
NICK BUTCHER: It's
a hot topic.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
For sure.
So, moving on.
Then Nick and I did a session
called Android Design for UI
Developers.
And this was kind of more
like a developer talk.
It wasn't really so much for
designers, but I think
especially Nick's part, the
responsive design area--
this was incredibly useful for
both designers and developers.
So at a very high level,
we covered navigation--
so we covered how
to implement the
navigation drawer, for example.
And then Nick did a whole big
bit on responsive design
techniques, and Nick,
I'm sure you want to
talk about that here.
And then I finished off with
implementing the Holo visual
language, like how to implement
dividers and touch
feedback and different
things like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I took the
opportunity of having the
stage at I/O to talk about one
of my favorite topics, which
is responsive design.
So [INAUDIBLE]
talking about some of the
limitations of the scalable
approach and discussed some
strategies you can use to deal
with that, to cope with it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
It's very, very good
information, especially for
developers.
So if you're a designer and your
developers come back to
you and say, oh, that's going
to take too long and I don't
know how to do it, whatever.
Just point them to
this session.
There's a lot of good
information here.
ADAM KOSH: Yeah.
I have nothing else
to add other than
go watch the session.
It's a good one.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Really quickly--
two things that we, again,
talked about for developers--
the navigation drawer, and then
Nick talked about sliding
pane layout, which is sort of a
new presentation for master
detail views--
and Google Hangouts is
an example of an
app that uses this--
where basically on a phone, it's
a single pane that slides
off the screen to reveal
the master pane.
And on a tablet, they're both
visible at the same time.
There's obviously a lot more
detail to that pattern there.
But in case you're a developer
and looking to implement that,
basically look at the navigation
drawer guide here,
with this link at the top, and
then the sliding pane layout
link is a link to
the reference.
There's no actual design guide
topic for sliding panes right
now, but that's kind of the
best place to look at for
basic information about it--
obviously in this session,
as well.
Yeah.
So for those watching, our
awesome producer [INAUDIBLE]
has just told us that Nick's
audio is, yet again, on only
the left channel.
Sorry about that.
If you can't hear Nick and only
one ear is plugged in,
just switch to the other ear.
Sorry about that.
We'll fix that for
the next time.
ADAM KOSH: It's sort of like
a repeating problem.
NICK BUTCHER: Am I speaking out
of the corner of my mouth
again [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
All right.
So this is actually an
interesting one, "An
Engineer's Pragmatic Guide to
Design" from Braden Kowitz.
I heard about this, but there's
still no video up, so
we can't really talk about it.
ADAM KOSH: We all heard good
things, but there's no video
up, so we haven't had a chance
to watch it because we
couldn't attend in person.
So we're looking forward
to watching it.
ROMAN NURIK: It looks
really good.
That's all I can say.
But just check out this link
down here at the bottom.
I'm sure the YouTube video will
be posted at some point.
It's just a matter of time.
But, yeah, it's probably going
to be a really good session.
Or if it was a really good
session and you were there,
feel free to say so
in the comments.
And then there was another
session from some YouTube
folks on "Designing Products
for a Multi-Screen World--
The YouTube Perspective." It's
Tom Broxon and Josh Sassoon.
I hope that's right.
And my favorite thing
about this was
actually these charts.
They basically did a whole bunch
of research into how
people use their devices.
So this wasn't an
Android-specific talk.
This was basically looking at
Android, iPhone, TV, iPad,
Android tablets--
ADAM KOSH: Every screen that you
could possibly want to use
or consume content in.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, basically
every screen that's--
Yeah.
And so they created these like
little diagram journals of how
people use their devices.
So this is basically like a time
graph, where I think it's
just kind of a full day.
And they just highlighted the
portions where people were
using their devices.
And so they made little
observations around, like,
people mostly user phones
throughout the entire day,
kind of snacking a little bit
of time, whereas the TV
portion of your usage was more
towards the nighttime,
obviously, with very,
very kind of
heavy continuous portions.
So some of these charts are very
interesting to watch, and
they definitely made some
good observations.
NICK BUTCHER: I've yet to say
it yet, but I think it's a
really interesting space, as
well-- how we deal with the
multi-device when everyone has
all these different devices.
I think it's really
interesting.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, another thing
that was really good about
this is that--
so YouTube is obviously a very
popular brand, and one of the
things that's very important to
them is maintaining their
brand across different
platforms.
And there's especially a part
at the end where they talked
about how did they reconcile
their brand with the platform.
And I think it was Tom that
mentioned this, but he's
basically like, we want to be
true to our brand, and we want
to be true to the platform, but
we don't want to sacrifice
one over the other.
So if you're working with
somebody, or project managers
or developers that
are thinking--
or designers--
that we really need this to be
fully brand consistent, there
are definitely ways to achieve
that while not letting
platform conventions stop you
or anything like that.
ADAM KOSH: Yeah, it's a very
common question we get asked
around that.
ROMAN NURIK: And I think we
want to do another session
just on this at some point.
NICK BUTCHER: I think we should
do an entire show on
that subject.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
There's a lot to talk
about there.
All right.
So moving on from
the sessions.
Those are just some
of the sessions.
I think design was probably
mentioned in more areas.
But we also had a few labs, or,
I guess, workshops at I/O
that were related to design.
The first was from Nazmul
and Izabel--
"UX Design for Developers."
So this is a very,
very popular workshop.
I think it was so popular
and there was too
much overflow, I guess--
too many people trying to get
in that couldn't-- that they
actually had to redo
the session.
They did two versions
of the session
just to fit the demand.
So this was an incredibly
popular session.
They also talked about use
cases, just like Rich and Jens
did in their talk.
They also talked about
personas-- so basically the
process of doing some
high level UX--
I guess thinking through the UX
for your product, thinking
about who was using it, and
then thinking through the
different use cases and
prioritizing them.
So basically they went through
the process, I think, of doing
this for a pizza ordering type
app, and it was basically a
lot of folks just
wireframing and
diagramming it out on paper.
So as you can see here--
NICK BUTCHER: A quick
note on these labs.
Unfortunately, these labs
weren't recorded, and so you
won't be able to watch it, but
some materials might be
available if you want to work
through the lab in your time.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So these links here
aren't to videos--
these links at the bottom
are to the materials.
So for this UX Design for
Developers lab, this link
actually points you to
developerlife.com/UX.
They started kind of a blog, and
also a Google+ community
just for this project.
And it's very, very popular.
So if you're interested in UX
design, if you're interested
in learning about it, definitely
this is a very good
beginner guide to it.
Moving on.
Then Nick, Adam, and I, we also
ran our Android Design in
Action Live lab.
And this is also
quite popular.
We only did one of these.
But basically what we did is we
kind of took an alternative
approach to a very
similar problem.
Rather than doing the standard
classical personas and use
cases stuff, we thought about
it a little more from an
engineering standpoint--
the different objects you
work with, the different
connections between them, and
the different ways to group
screens and such.
And so for about two hours,
folks came to the lab.
They worked with pencil and
paper, and we gave out sketch
pads and things like that, and
we just had a whole bunch of
fun going through the process
of creating a mobile banking
application for teenagers,
which is kind of an
interesting little
problem there.
But my favorite thing,
I'd say, about
this was these guys--
everybody that came,
thanks for coming.
One of my favorite things that
happened was that we actually
got together a whole
bunch of folks
from the design community.
Like Taylor Ling was there, we
had Lucas Rocha from Pattern,
Walmer from Brazil.
A whole bunch of folks were
there as TAs, so they walked
around and helped people
as they had questions.
What did you guys think of the
experience of the live lab?
ADAM KOSH: I thought
it was really cool.
it was definitely something
we haven't done before.
Normally, we're used to doing
code labs at Google I/O, so it
was something new
and different.
And I was just really impressed
with all of the work
that the attendees came
up with at the end.
So I think we may post some
of those at some point?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
at some point.
ADAM KOSH: Or we'll
see how we go.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
I made sure to capture the G+
profiles of all the winners--
well, the winners.
I think the TAs selected like
four or five different apps
to, I guess, to win.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm pretty sure
that during the lab, you said
they were all winners,
you big cheeseball.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, that's right.
Well, they are all winners,
basically.
It was really, really good.
ADAM KOSH: It was good.
ROMAN NURIK: I think this
is a good photo of it.
We said we have time for 10 or
15 presentations, but at least
30 or 40 people came up to try
to present their work, which
was just kind of awesome.
ADAM KOSH: Oh, and by the way,
these were hand-sketched
designs in the end.
Some people did use their
computers, but for the most
part, they were hand-sketched,
which was really cool.
NICK BUTCHER: The two things
I liked about the lab was
because it's a developer
conference-- and
we polled the audience.
It was primarily developers
there.
And we said we want to introduce
you to the concepts,
how you think through your
application and sketch it all
out, rather than just, which I
think a lot of people do, is
dive into the code too quickly
and invest a lot of time in
something which they then
might throw away.
So it's really interesting to
get people thinking about
sketching and thinking through
the problem space a lot more,
applying the design rigor a lot
more before jumping into
code, which is really
interesting.
And also, I want to second, it
was great to meet a bunch of
the people.
So some of the really active
people in the Android design
community-- so you might have
seen them joining the ADiA
Hangouts we've had a couple of
times and posting on the G+
community on the hashtag #ADiA
and #AndroidDesign.
It was really great to
meet those guys.
They rock.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
Totally.
OK, so that was the lab.
And again, if you're interested
in running through
it at home, just visit this link
here and it points you to
a Google Drive folder containing
all the slides and
everything.
All right.
NICK BUTCHER: It's
j.mp/adialive.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
So I think that was
it for I/O--
oh, wait.
No, there was more.
Did we miss-- oh, no.
That's right.
That's part of the news.
So there was more, obviously,
with Google I/O 2013.
We'll mention a couple
of things about
apps that were launched--
Google Apps that were updated.
Actually, before we talk about
the awesome ADiA Android app,
any parting thoughts for Google
I/O 2013, the in-person
experience?
ADAM KOSH: For me, it was just
great to see a heavier design
focus than previous years,
especially on the Android
side, of course.
There was just a really
great vibe there.
I really enjoyed it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
For those of you who didn't get
to attend, there's a bunch
of stuff that happens at I/O
that isn't recorded in the
sessions and so on.
So we were involved with a bunch
of panels, for example,
where we were meeting developers
who were talking
about how they found
success or their
experiences with Android.
And one of the things that came
through for me was the
importance of Android design.
A lot of businesses were saying
this has impacted
numbers we care about, like
install numbers and revenue
and so on because we've adopted
the Android design
principles.
So I think it really shows the
maturity of the Android user
base out there, and how they
really appreciate a
well-designed app.
That was cool.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and actually
some of that is
captured in the Biz Dev Bites
video series that we published
around the same time as I/O.
So if you're interested in
hearing real-world product
managers, designers,
developers talk about their
experience not only with the
design guide and using things
like responsive design, but
also just with the impact of
those types of things and
those kind of technical
changes--
the impact on that on their key
numbers, the things that
they care about--
definitely check out the Biz
Dev Bites series on Android
Developers, the YouTube
channel.
So my parting thought is it was
obviously awesome to meet
everybody again.
It's always kind of stressful
for folks on the Android
team-- or I guess anybody
working at Google that's
staffing I/O--
to take care of.
But I think this year more
than other years it was a
little more relaxed, and it was
definitely able to engage
more in kind of friendly
conversations with developers
rather than jumping around
between different places.
So it was definitely an
awesome conference.
If you didn't get to attend this
year, definitely try to
attend next year.
And, yeah, here's to
Google I/O 2014.
All right.
So let's talk about the
ADiA Android App.
So I'm going to butcher his
name, unfortunately--
Andreas Stutz.
Is that right?
So sorry if we pronounced
it wrong, Andreas--
really sorry.
But this app is awesome.
ADAM KOSH: It's top notch.
It's really good.
ROMAN NURIK: We actually
have it here.
Let's really quickly
switch over to it.
So this is the app.
It basically let's you look at
past episodes of ADiA it lets
look at all the slides, it lets
you watch the videos.
ADAM KOSH: It notifies you
of upcoming shows.
NICK BUTCHER: Can you play an
episode of ADiA in ADiA
ADAM KOSH: Yeah.
Let's see if we can do
the "Inception."
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROMAN NURIK: Let's
see if we can do
the current one that's--
oh my god.
ADAM KOSH: Oh yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: It's working.
ADAM KOSH: Oh, but it's a bit
delayed, so we don't see the
screen of the screen
and the screen.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So you can basically watch
Android Design in Action.
You can also participate
in some of the Google+
conversation and Google+
activity on
Android design and #ADiA.
And it's just an overall
well-built app, too, so it's
just a good example of a
well-built, responsibly
designed Holo app.
It's just an awesome
app all around.
I definitely recommend
downloading it.
NICK BUTCHER: So thank
you, Andreas.
It's been really
useful for me.
So a bunch of people, they come
up and ask me for design
feedback, and I can say,
hey, oh yeah, we talked
about this on ADiA.
And I can put up my tablet
and put up the
redesign very easily.
So it's been phenomenal to
be able to have that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
For sure.
So next, this new tool--
well, I guess this old existing
tool, Scala Preview.
First of all, it now has an
Android version, so you can
actually mirror what's
on your computer to
your Android device--
very similar to Android Design
Preview, the tool that we
talked about I think
a few weeks ago.
But this is now free, and it
also works over Wi-Fi.
So basically it's almost the
same thing as Android Design
Preview, but it works over Wi-Fi
and probably has a few
other features.
I haven't used it myself, but
it's definitely good if you're
a designer and interested in
seeing real-world scenarios of
how your designs look
on those devices.
So, yeah.
So that's now free.
Go ahead and get it.
ADAM KOSH: Maybe we should
jump to the apps first.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Let's do this one first.
So there are a couple of new app
updates that came around
the time of Google I/O. The
first and I guess the biggest
to me is the Google Play
Music redesign.
So first of all, we launched
Google Play Music All Access.
It's a monthly subscription,
you get whatever music.
And as part of that launch, we
also updated this new UI.
So I think one of the best
things about this is that,
first of all, it uses new
patterns and things like that.
It's obviously a very
responsive app.
It has a very clean--
ADAM KOSH: It's got
the drawer.
ROMAN NURIK: It's got
the drawer, yeah.
But it's also just filled with
interesting design touches,
like fading semi-translucent
action bars and lots of
different swipeable panels.
It's just really cool overall.
NICK BUTCHER: I think it's
a phenomenal app.
It has got, like you say, some
design flourishes in there
that they've really thought
through all the minute and
minor details that it's worth
spending a good 20 minutes,
half an hour playing
with it, just--
ROMAN NURIK: Did we lose Nick?
Nick seems to have frozen up.
ADAM KOSH: All right.
Well, keep going.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So, what Nick said.
And there's also Google
Hangouts, which is a new app,
obviously, and it's a
messaging-type app.
It lets you communicate with
people via, obviously
pictures, text, and video
using Video Hangouts.
But it's a new app, and it uses
that sliding pane layout
that we talked about earlier.
And there are a whole bunch
of other updates.
There's obviously
the I/O 2013--
Nick is back.
Thanks for coming, Nick.
Sorry to have lost you
the first time.
There's obviously, also, the
Google I/O application, which
will be open sourced
at some point.
The Google+ app got updates--
a whole bunch of updates
across the board, the Play
apps especially.
Play Music, Play Books, Play
Magazines, they've gotten this
new, consistent visual styling
across the board.
ADAM KOSH: Which matches
the Google Play Store.
Oh, we lost Nick again.
ROMAN NURIK: And Nick's
lost again.
But anyway, so the reason we
wanted to talk about this
really quickly is that one of
those design touches is this
kind of fading semi-translucent
action bar.
And Cyril Mottier actually wrote
up a blog post on how to
do this in your own apps.
So here's a quick couple of
screenshots of what it
actually looks like.
ADAM KOSH: And I think he's got
a sample APK you can just
go and install if you want to
actually play with it, because
I think you have to see it in
motion to really sort of
understand it, but--
NICK BUTCHER: And then someone
else has also turned it into a
library on GitHub if you
want to [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM KOSH: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
Great stuff.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
I'm sure they'll link
up at some point.
The idea is that you have this
kind of transparent action bar
that shows content at the top.
But as soon as you start
scrolling, it becomes solid.
So it's a very cool effect.
It's definitely worth
considering
for one of your apps.
So that was that.
And then I think this
may be the last one.
The last one is--
and this is, I think,
a few weeks old.
But in case you're interested
in using some of the action
bar icon pack icons, so like
Refresh and Share and things
like that, in case you don't
want to necessarily use the
Illustrator version or the
Photoshop version-- there's
like a million different
versions available.
There's now a font for this.
So you basically just
install this font.
It's kind of like Wingdings
or Webdings
or symbol or whatever.
But you can just type in the
right character, and you
instantly get that icon.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE] quite
handy if you're doing
some wireframes or something
like that.
If you want to do some
high-fidelity wireframes or do
an action bar, and action with
an icon in text, you can do it
really easily.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
It's one way to speed up your
workflow and just really
streamline your process,
so it's very cool.
OK.
So I think that's it.
That's all the time
we have today.
That was kind of a whiz bang
tour of Google I/O 2013--
the different sessions that we
had, the different labs that
took place, and also some of the
news that came out of that
as well as some of the news
around that time.
So thanks for joining, and
again, we're probably going to
try to get back into our regular
cadence of Android
Design in Action episodes.
Sorry for the very long hiatus,
but we're now free.
We have nothing else to
do-- just kidding.
So we hope to see you
next week or the
week after, or whatever.
So thanks.
I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOSH: See you
later, guys.
My name's Adam Kosh.
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks very
much from Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: Later, guys.
ADAM KOSH: Bye.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye.